en el vídeo del enigma de p el
coeficiente de precio por ganancia
tenemos una situación en la cual dos
emprendedores ambos compraron un activo
idéntico en este caso era una taquería
la cosa es que cada uno lo financió a su
manera acá a la izquierda era muy
conservador lo pago en efectivo
entonces todo el activo era su capital
no tenía nada de deuda acá a la derecha
él tomó prestado un poco del banco
consiguió activos no operativos así que
hizo apalancamiento por cada peso que
puso tomó prestado 10 pesos del banco
para comprar más activos que pues
finalmente acabó usando en otras cosas
pero bueno cuando hicimos sus estados
financieros
vimos que ingreso costo de bienes
vendidos hasta utilidad operativa todo
era igualito y eso tenía sentido porque
si nos acordamos de la introducción al
estado de resultados la utilidad
operativa pues es un indicador de que
están generando los activos operativos a
la izquierda es que está generando esta
caja morada de acá esto que está de este
lado verdad y acá a la derecha es esta
cajita de aquí a esto también se le
conoce como la empresa lo que ayuda a
llevar a cabo el activo
empresarial todo lo que está debajo de
la línea operativa debajo de la utilidad
operativa viene uno de activos no
operativos como este efectivo que acá
abajo al emprendedor de la derecha le da
un ingreso no operativos de dos mil
pesos al año al de la izquierda pues no
le daba nada verdad viene de eso o bien
de gastos de intereses el de la derecha
tenía que pagar 5% por un préstamo de
100 mil pesos o sea cinco mil pesos al
año luego pues claro si tenemos esta
diferencia en estructura de capital pues
también cambia el ingreso neto y así las
taquerías tenían ingresos netos
distintos pero parecidos ahora aplica y
además tenían la misma cantidad de
acciones en realidad no cambiamos muchas
variables verdad nada más cambiamos como
pagaron por su activo pero bueno cuando
aplicamos el mismo coeficiente de
precios por ganancia a ambas empresas a
ambas ganancias habíamos obtenido algo
que parecía pues más o menos anti
intuitivo y realmente aquí no hay ningún
truco en no hay ningún truco bajo la
manga porque no está muy alocado ponerle
el mismo precio por ganancias de hecho
si lo intentas si incrementas el ingreso
de ventas de este o más bien
si incrementas el ingreso de los dos en
la misma cantidad o la misma utilidad
bruta o la misma
utilidad operativa las aumentas en la
misma cantidad
vas a darte cuenta que este gp a
ganancias por acción va a crecer más
rápido y entonces incluso aquí podría
decir ahora voy a pagar un poco más de
peso por ganancias por el apalancamiento
así que no está muy alocado poner el
mismo coeficiente este p en el vídeo
pasado dijimos que era uno de 10 verdad
esto si aplicamos un múltiplo de 10 y
tenemos una situación que no se vería
muy loca verdad la capitalización del
mercado desde la izquierda de la 210 mil
por el múltiplo de 10 y el de la derecha
era de 189 mil nada raro verdad como era
era 18 mil 900 por 10 que 189 mil y a la
izquierda es 21000 por 10 es 210 mil
ahora lo que era el enigma lo que nos
hizo pensar es cómo puede ser que este
capital
todo este cuadrito de acá valga 210 mil
pesos y el de la derecha valga 189 mil
pesos cuando el cuate de la derecha puso
diez mil pesos y el de la izquierda puso
cien mil pesos 10 veces más y no sólo
eso ahora si vemos en términos de
activos si aquí pagamos 210 mil por el
capital estamos diciendo que el activo
también vale 210 mil y a la derecha si
este cachito vale 189 mil este cuadrito
de aquí la capitalización de mercado
entonces estamos diciendo que todo el
activo el activo total vale lo mismo que
el valor de esta capitalización de
mercado más la deuda osea 289 mil pesos
de modo que si queremos el valor del
activo operativo hay que quitar este
efectivo y nos quedaba 279 mil entonces
al aplicar el mismo precio por ganancias
a las ganancias de negocios similares
llegamos a una situación donde estamos
pagando de más por este activo comparado
con este de acá aunque sean idénticos
entonces la pregunta era qué hacemos o
sea que podemos utilizar
el precio por ganancias pues este vídeo
justo es para eso la respuesta corta es
pues que tenemos que utilizar otro
indicador verdad precio por ganancias
pues es una forma rápida de comparar dos
compañías pues con respecto a su
crecimiento dentro de una misma
industria lo malo de este coeficiente es
que pierden mucha información de cómo
fueron capitalizadas las compañías en el
vídeo pasado vimos que era importante
cómo se capitalizaba y capitalizar es
como pagar un por su activo pero bueno
si tienes un montón de deuda contra un
montón de capital entonces lo que
empieza a pasar en las líneas de
ganancias es muy muy diferente
pierdes esta información de cómo se
capitalizó de modo que si quieres
recuperarla cuando ves el precio de una
acción también tienes que fijarte en el
valor de la empresa cuánto es el valor
empresarial ese es un concepto
importante valor empresarial la idea es
muy sencilla valor empresarial es
básicamente hablar de los activos
operativos estos de acá ok se hace un
poquito más complicado si tienes una
compañía financiera como un banco o una
de seguros pero si estamos hablando de
una fábrica de artesanías o de una
taquería básicamente son los activos que
se usan para la actividad
la operación del negocio pues ya sabes
en el caso de una taquería sería el
trompo las mesas las sillas el uniforme
del taquero los cuchillos y todo eso
pues vaya incluso también un poco de
efectivo ojo pero nada más el efectivo
que está en la caja registradora o sea
no debe de incluir el efectivo de afuera
el efectivo que es excedente que no sea
necesario para la operación bueno
entonces ahora esto nos lleva a la
pregunta de cómo calcular el valor
empresarial ahí te va primero vamos a
empezar al revés es decir por un precio
de acción dado cuando estoy diciendo que
es el valor empresarial usted supongamos
que esta acción supongamos que la
compañía a la taquería a
no sé sus acciones están cotizando en 20
pesos en 20 pesos en la bolsa mexicana
de valores y que ve este de aquí es el
precio así lo puedes comprar y vender en
el mercado y para la compañía ve digamos
que se está cotizando en 10 pesos
10 pesos entonces a primera vista pues
podríamos hacer un p
un coeficiente p entonces por 20 pesos
estoy obteniendo 2 pesos con 10 centavos
de ganancia por año entonces el precio
por ganancias aproximadamente es no sé
cuánto sea 20 entre 2.1 pero es como 9
punto y cachito 9 y tantos de este lado
es 10 pesos por una ganancia por acción
de 1.89 pesos al año y 100 entre 1.89
creo que es como 5 o 6 más como 5 punto
y cachito verdad 6 por 18 ya se pasa
entonces si va a ser 5 punto y cachito
ok entonces cuando vemos esto
superficialmente podríamos decir que el
de la derecha tenía un precio por
ganancias más barato y a lo mejor
deberíamos comprarlo pero como vimos en
el vídeo pasado precio por ganancias no
es una buena métrica cuando tenemos dos
compañías que están capitalizadas muy
diferente mente entonces lo que hacemos
en vez de esto es ver qué nos dicen
estos precios en términos de valor
empresarial que dice este 20 del valor
de la empresa y que dice este 10
cómo le hacemos para hacer esto pues
empezamos con la capitalización de
mercado capitalización de mercado
entonces hay que tomar el precio por la
cantidad de acciones que si recuerdo
bien son diez mil entonces en este caso
veinte por diez mil sería doscientos mil
de capitalización de mercado y acá es 10
x 10 mil que sería 100 mil pesos ok
ahora recordemos la capitalización de
mercado es simplemente que 'queda ofrece
el capital déjame dibujar las hojas de
balance porque es más fácil hacerlo así
entonces aquí voy a poner para este
emprendedor sus activos y no tiene nada
de deuda verdad entonces todo el activo
es capital entonces todo de esto de acá
este cuadro naranja es el capital
entonces si la capitalización de mercado
de 200 mil esencialmente estamos
diciendo que el activo el activo
operativo también vale 200 mil pesos
en este caso verdad si tenemos un precio
por ganancias de un precio de acción de
20 pesos entonces el valor empresarial
lo que el mercado dice que vale la
empresa lo que en el mercado dice que
vale el activo operativo es 200 mil
pesos
ahora a la derecha recuerda el mercado
está diciendo que el capital vale 100
mil pesos déjame dibujarlo el capital
vale 100 mil pesos 100 mil pero por
supuesto esta compañía tiene un montón
de deuda verdad tiene otros 100 mil
pesos en deuda déjame no voy a dibujar
mejor para que quede proporcional déjame
borrar
no voy a hablar con un cuadrito negro ok
bueno entonces en esta situación el
mercado está diciendo que la
capitalización del mercado es de 100 mil
pesos déjame ser proporcional lo voy a
dibujar así
a chino no no quiero que quede relleno
no quiero una tarjeta amarilla
así exacto 100 mil pesos estoy aquí es
el capital o más bien lo que el mercado
dice que vale el capital la
capitalización del mercado entonces
estoy acá y es 100 mil pesos y además
tiene deuda déjame poner un cuadrito de
deuda si recuerdo bien eran 100 mil
pesos en deuda ajá entonces tienes 100
mil pesos en deuda déjame poner un
cuadrito para indicar eso
entonces 100 mil pesos en deudas y esta
herramienta de rectángulo es este
cuadradito azul
y le voy a escribir aquí 100 mil pesos
ok
hasta entonces esencialmente esto que
dice acerca del activo pues el capital
base el pasivo es 200 mil pesos entonces
todo el activo incluyendo el activo no
operativo vale 200 mil pesos según el
mercado esto de acá es todo todo el
activo verdad 200 mil pesos pero lo que
queremos determinar es el valor de
empresa no sólo de todos los activos
entonces si nos acordamos había por aquí
un poquito de efectivo como te comentaba
que estábamos utilizando para hacer
actividades no operativas actividades en
la bolsa entonces déjame indicarlo aquí
en la hoja de balance son diez mil pesos
en efectivo entonces cuando cuando esta
acción se cotiza en la bolsa a 10 pesos
quiere decir que la capitalización del
mercado de 100 mil 100 mil pesos más el
pasivo sería 200 mil entonces todo está
activo toda esta parte izquierda vale
200 mil así que tenemos que restar estos
10 mil pesos porque no es necesario para
operar el negocio y queda 190 mil pesos
de valor empresarial
lo escribo acá el valor empresarial es
de 190 mil pesos
muy bien así cuando vemos en el precio
por ganancias aquí parece ser un súper
barato verdad parece un muy buen negocio
pero acabo de hacer los numeritos de
modo tal que aquí no se vea tan barato
solo se ve que como 5% más barato arriba
se ve 50% más barato bueno vamos a la
definición que está un poquito anti
intuitiva la fórmula que usamos y que
así voy a poner en los libros es valor
empresarial es igual a capitalización de
mercado que usualmente la encontramos
multiplicando precio por acciones más
deuda menos efectivo y esto se ve un
poco raro verdad porque si encontramos
el valor de algo que estamos sumando a
la deuda la deuda es algo malo no
debería hacer que el valor sea menor
porque restamos el efectivo el efectivo
debería de ser algo bueno no el efectivo
debería de aumentar el valor bueno la
razón por la cual restamos efectivo y
bueno en realidad sólo debería de ser el
efectivo que no tenga que ver con las
operaciones bueno en gustos se rompen
géneros y hay personas que lo hacen de
otras formas una resta en todo el
efectivo para mí pues es más convincente
nada más restar el efectivo que no tenga
que ver con las operaciones del negocio
el efectivo que no ayude a hacer
operativa bueno pensando así las cosas
tiene sentido restarlo porque no es una
parte fundamental de la empresa ahora
pasemos a por qué se suma la deuda y más
o menos se puede pensar así si quisieras
comprar toda esta compañía o sea no sé
digamos que de la compañía quieres
comprar le todo el activo operativo a
digamos precio de mercado que tendrías
que hacer bueno número uno tendrías que
pagar
200 mil pesos verdad tendrás que pagar
200 mil pesos con 100 mil pesos pagarías
el capital con eso ya compraste el
capital y luego con los otros 100 mil
pesos podrías comprar el banco sea
pagarle al banco pues entonces ya
pagando los 200 mil pesos ya eres dueño
de todo lo de la derecha todo esto sería
tu capital y luego como ya eres dueño de
todo podrías quedarte con este efectivo
entonces esencialmente pagaste 200 mil
que es capitalización más deuda eso es
lo que tendrías que hacer para pagarle
pues a estas partes interesadas de la
compañía y luego obtendrías un poco de
efectivo de regreso así que en total
tendrías que pagar 190 mil pesos para
ser dueño del activo operativo bueno
entonces por eso pues tiene sentido que
el valor empresarial tenga esta ecuación
ahora me puedes decir ok ya me enseñaste
a encontrar el valor empresarial a
partir del precio de la acción pero qué
tal que queremos hacerlo al revés qué
tal que queremos ver cuánto debería de
ser el valor de una acción basado en lo
que creemos que es su valor empresarial
bueno vamos a hacerlo acá arriba hay dos
formas de hacerlo lo más común es
utilizar el evita ahorita no lo voy a
decir muy muy a profundidad pero el
ganancias antes de intereses impuestos
depreciación y amortización
algunas personas se fijan en el
coeficiente valor empresarial entrevista
que veremos en el siguiente vídeo pero
la forma en la cual yo lo voy a hacer es
cuáles fueron las ganancias reales de la
empresa a proceso se calcula con la
utilidad operativa verdad después vamos
a multiplicar esa utilidad operativa por
un coeficiente que depende pues de la
industria y del crecimiento así que pues
no sé ahorita ambas se están generando
una ganancia de 30 mil pesos de utilidad
operativa y digamos que la rama de
taquerías pues el coeficiente que se
aplica es digamos multiplicar por 5
entonces vamos a multiplicar por cinco
la utilidad operativa y no sé déjame
calcular entonces esta cosa de acá
arriba
qué valor empresarial / / utilidad
operativa que según yo es una mejor
medida que evita pero bueno en el
siguiente vídeo hablaré de evitar
supongamos que creo que para la
industria de las taquerías debería de
ser 5 no mejor 66 es un buen número con
muchos divisores entonces en ambos casos
la utilidad operativa será de 30 mil
y entonces eso quiere decir que el valor
empresarial debería de ser 30 mil x 6
que es igual a 180 mil pesos ok entonces
para el primer cuarto el valor
empresarial es de 180 mil pesos es decir
estoy diciendo que esté activo operativo
de acá el mercado debería de valer 180
mil pesos pero también estoy diciendo
que el capital debería de valer 180 mil
va entonces como además hay 10.000
acciones ahora que ya podemos calcular
todo entonces ahí va otra vez y entonces
déjame ponerlo por aquí o sea como el
valor empresarial es 180 mil y no hay
deuda no hay efectivo que sobre todo
esto es capital entonces tendría que
dividir la capitalización de mercado que
es 180 mil pesos entre la cantidad de
acciones 10.000 entonces el precio por
acción debería de ser 18 pesos porque
teníamos 10.000 acciones ahora vamos con
el segundo cuate con la segunda taquería
pues estábamos de acuerdo en que el
valor de estos activos el valor de
mercado y el valor empresarial debería
de ser de 180 mil pesos pero en este
caso cuánto es el activo cual es el
activo de acá déjame ponerlo aquí pues
el activo es los 180 mil más diez mil en
efectivo verdad diez mil de efectivo no
opera activo
esto es todo el lado izquierdo 190 mil
pesos pero luego si queremos determinar
la capitalización de mercado hay que
quitarle la deuda de acá si verdad
haciendo esto nos quedaría este cachito
esta altura de acá que sería el capital
simplemente es toda esta distancia menos
toda esta distancia
ok entonces la capitalización de mercado
un mercado es igual al valor empresarial
180 10 menos la deuda la deuda es de
100.000 menos 100.000 entonces la
capitalización de mercado es 180 más de
190 menos 10 90 mil 90 mil pesos si
dividimos esto entre las 10 mil acciones
entonces el precio por acción que estoy
dispuesto a pagar es de 9 pesos entonces
si crees que el valor empresarial de
estas taquerías es idéntico que ambas
valen
180 mil entonces deberías estar
dispuesto a pagar 18 pesos por acción
por compañía y si es completamente
equivalente debería de pagar 9 pesos por
la compañía ve ahora si fuera un poco
más agresivo y confías en el
apalancamiento debe podrías pagar un
poco más podrías pagar un excedente oa
lo mejor un poco menos porque crees que
tiene más riesgo eso depende de tu
estrategia personal sale y vale es lo
que quería contarte en este vídeo en el
siguiente voy a hablar del evita